he's head coach of the Duke Blue Devils
he's Mike sous-chefs key back on the
program good morning coach how are you
today yeah good thank you happy New Year
to you and yours and excited to be
talking to you today what did you do on
New Year's Eve on New Year's Eve wasn't
it theirs cuz we just had practice so I
was practice planning for what we were
doing on New Year's Day and watching
practice tape living it up well no but I
like to do that and we had just
completed a great Christmas because we
had our we have our 10 grandchildren
right here in Durham now our three
daughters and their husbands and so for
a few days a couple days they were all
at our house and and and then we get a
chance to we had a break a longer break
this year so when we came back we had
kind of like to get back into like
training camp for our guys and so New
Year's Eve and New Year's Day that right
in the middle of our preparation for
when we started our conference games
against Clemson
what are your grandkids call you poppy
also no Kaleo no KY no Coach K no coach
no an interesting a really crazy story
for and what guys a guy mistake you know
when our my daughter Debbie was was
pregnant with her first child and we are
together as a family and we were talking
about what do you what do you want to be
called and I obviously it's a guy I've
never thought of that a second in my
whole life and
so I did what guys shouldn't do I gave
an immediate response and not knowing
what the heck I was saying instead of
saying what do you think and I said
coach as soon as I said coach four women
just attacked me just and I'm sitting
there saying you are such an idiot like
all you have to do is say what do you
think and none of this would be
happening so four guys out there don't
do that find out what they want and and
go along with it how does having three
daughters help you as a coach
yeah it's tremendously and I if I had
three more kids I'd want three more
daughters they you know one you're their
guy for life you know it's a different
relationship and and they they bring a
certain amount of wisdom that that you
don't see just being with the guys all
the time and it was just me and my
brother and what's all boys school West
Point was all boys as in the military as
an officer you know and all of a sudden
I have you know my family with four
women my wife and my three daughters and
I'd loved it and you know my daughter or
my best friend so my wife is still my
good friend so so but it just gives you
different perspectives and different
feelings to understand and it and
they've been an integral part of of my
career it's our career we actually have
a group text that I just kind of watch
all the time and we call it the starting
five and you know the five of us and you
know we've been a really good team
throughout my 44 years as uh as a as a
head coach would they tell you when to
retire
no they uh no they but any day will tell
me the truth like if I'm being a if I'm
being an idiot about sad what are you
doing here what are you wearing girl why
did you do that and what are you wearing
that yeah I'm okay usually with that
that what am i doing or wire you know
what come on
and overall though really good and they
tell you the truth right now but they
also for the most part are just saying
what a you know would it would are not
that I am you know what a stud guy I am
to them you know they're you know like
you know they tell me wise you know and
make me feel good for the most part they
tell me really good things really really
good thing I have three daughters as
well and the one thing that it taught me
more than anything is to be a good
listener and yeah that's a great point
that's an that's a great point and and
they want to do it on your show why
don't you do that on your show there's
even better Whistler I'm listening right
now I'm all ears
I'm the only one listening to you but
I'm listening to you I know I was
curious you're right you know another
thing with that growing up with these
with our kids at the dinner table I
don't care if we've just you know we're
getting ready to play Carolina or just
did or in the NC double-a tournament
when we're added we're at the dinner
table we didn't talk about basketball at
all we're talking about what happened
that day and
and which is kind of cool
and my wife did a really neat things
growing with the kids growing up we
never had anything pictures of
basketball statues trophies or anything
in our in our house
and we only had their stuff and so we
celebrated what they were doing and we
should and and they yeah I've never had
them say you know dad you a basketball
more than me or any of that you know
that kind of stuff so it's it's been a
good thing when did they know you were
famous I don't know I think when we
started winning you know going to Final
Fours they know that was pretty cool and
you know late 80 in the 80s
well mid it mid to late 80s you know we
went to water Final Fours and won our
first two championships in 91 92 and a
really neat thing when I was the US
coach for the three Olympics two of them
Beijing and London I took all my whole
family all my grandkids and that was
great and and in Rio two of the families
were able to come so that yeah we've
we've kind of done things as a family
he's Mike sous chef ski the Duke head
coach joining us Continental Tire
Coach's Corner when you recruited Greg
Paulus he was a great high school
quarterback and obviously good enough to
play basketball and start at Duke but
was there any discussion of him being a
two sports star at Duke
No he he just we would we wouldn't have
recruited Hannah to be yeah
that way you know and he didn't want
that it's not like we put pressure on
him to do it but he he wanted to play
basketball and obviously well I don't
not officer but maybe people may not
know but after he graduated from Duke he
did go to Syracuse and play a
postgraduate year as their quarterback
and so he was a really good high school
quarterback and I was a really good
guard and when now he's an assistant
coach at GW at George Washington I
talked to Coach Calipari a couple of
times about this when you get these
one-and-done kids these kids who are
all-americans top five they know they're
gonna be first-round picks
trying to convince them to play team
basketball where they've been the star
the go-to guy preferential treatment and
the one thing that stands out continues
to stand out certainly with Zion
Williamson is it feels like he he seems
to have understood or understands team
first as well as any star player I've
seen in a long time and this is at an
early stage of his college career how
much development do you help with that
or is that just a Zion I think it's it's
pretty much him you know we recruited
him and actually our four freshmen are
very very similar in that regard there
they're what I call it as being secure
about who they are as players and they
don't need an individual spotlight they
want the spotlight on the team and their
their individual stuff will show they're
all about winning cuz eyen is all about
winning he's like a beautiful young man
to coach I mean not not good I mean
great yeah upbeat actually our kids came
in before class to have an early morning
list and breakfast and I saw him
downstairs as always
upbeat upbeat and team guy and he's
really a good basketball player you know
up until I think eighth grade he was not
as tall or big and and he played point
guard and so he understands the game
really well has really good ball
handling skills and he's and he keeps
growing as a player beautiful beautiful
kid to coach and obviously a great
talent you've had to encourage him to
shoot and I guess encourage him to shoot
the jumper is that why is he reticent
well you know it's uh he's a little bit
of a perfectionist and and he you know
his shooting percentage is off the
charts so anything going to the basket
he has if he misses he has an
extraordinary second jump you know I
like to go after a mess and I think it
comes from he doesn't like to miss and
boom he goes after it when he shoots a
jump shot or he doesn't even have to
shoot a jump shot it can be a set up
because of his driving ability dildo
play off and when he misses I think he
was looking at that as a mistake and and
what we've told him is you know you
you're gonna get 15 20 shots and the
ball in the ball game and it's you know
if you hit if you go to for five from
three or whatever that's that's okay or
even if you go old for three from three
and you're doing the other things that's
okay it'd just be don't look at it as a
mistake we just had a good game against
Wake Forest the other night and he was
13 for 16 from the floor and 3 for 4
from 3 and and two of the three misses
one was on a a dunk from right under the
bucket that just flew about 30 feet up
in the air and on a missed offensive
rebound other than that he missed one
three and so he's a credibly efficient
SCOR really and a really good passer the
kid is it there's a gym I mean he's
going to be obviously he's really good
an outstanding for us but he he has a
great great future yeah he's got a great
feel he and he seems to enjoy his
teammates success as much as if not more
so than his own success and then it's
rare and I was watching the Wake Forest
game I he has he's a good passer
probably an underrated pass or good
touch good feel for the game and I know
after the game he was like I don't want
to be known as a dunker yeah well that's
all people show yeah and and and I
understand that but he makes he's a
player he makes plays his lateral
quickness is crazy good and he's so easy
to play with and one of the really cool
things is his relationship not only not
with all of his teammates but especially
with RJ Barrett and and RJ isn't he's
one of the best players in the country
and the two of them are they're like
brother state they're with each other
all the time they're you know they it's
beautiful really to watch and it's not
contrived it's it's real and that our
team has that and hopefully we can
continue to get better with the
competition that will face and keep
learning and then by March becomes a you
know a very special team
do you miss recruiting the kid who's
going to be there for three or four
years I know you have some but you miss
yet no we still do and it's just you
know we go after the same level of young
man that we've always gone after you
know he's really good good student and a
good kid and it's just we can we attract
a high level of talent
and but we've all we've done that for a
long time and that high level of talent
now goes our way especially if we do a
good job with them and and put them in a
system that is more Pro white and we
feel like ours is uh we're not the only
ones that were you know we play man we
we run we teach team basketball we teach
them how to take care of themselves and
nutrition training and all that and so
they get better and and when the time
comes they are prepared and our guys who
are doing a good job in the NBA I can
make a guarantee that all be at the
Final Four this year I'm not sure if
you'll be there but if if Duke is lucky
enough to carry my team is there I'll be
there okay but if you're there I mean I
just in case if you need me to do a
drive-by shooting drills some
inspirational talk more happy to do that
coach recharge you know what I got an
idea if we're there I could bring
someone who's really successful and to
talk and have you talk and say look if
we win we're going to become this guy
yeah
if we don't win yes I'm gonna become me
this other yes okay I think we're you
have a show where no one listened split
the two of us are having how all the
talk so I bring in Roy Williams and he
talks and then and then I come in after
that he is very successful he's not
necessarily bring Roy into this this is
I do consider him a friend and very
successful so maybe in another in some
other context okay
all right Thank You coach good luck
against Florida State coming up on
Saturday we appreciate your time as yeah
they'll be a big big game thank you Dan
I appreciate all right that's coach Mike
sous-chefs key that I thought we just
bring in somebody successful very
successful and you bring in me
you don't want to be like that guy right
there you know what I would do I'd slap
the floor slowly second style yeah I
would go in and slap the floor
Continental Tire coaches corner proud to
be the exclusive tire the Dan Patrick
show no matter what you drive where you
drive how you drive continental designs
tires for what you do for more
information visit Continental Tire down
come Continental Tire for what you do
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]